foreign
Texas what's up Grace in the 512 how we
doing
Hi how are you I'm good talk to you it's
great to talk to you things okay
uh yeah it's a beautiful day excellent
yeah it is it is stunning out here in
Nashville today I'm glad that y'all
needs y'all need a beautiful day
yeah
bananas hey so what's up how can I help
okay so
um my question is
um how do I like release or let go of
this like perhaps unreasonable
bitterness that I have against my family
my parents specifically
um
and I know that's a super broad question
so I can explain it if you want can I
just start guessing things just kidding
yes of course explain it explain it okay
um so 10 years ago I was
in 2013
I guess it is
okay yeah 10 years it's crazy
um wow what were you doing there
oh I was cheering on my mom she was
racing
oh my gosh
yeah
um and like I was at the finish line and
thankfully like didn't die yeah for real
hey can we just park on that sentence
that's an important sentence
have you internalized that over the last
10 years
and I was like I've done good with that
with that gratefulness that I have okay
um it's a weird thing because
um you know no one thinks when they're
in like in Middle School that they're
just gonna go to a sporting event and
possibly like die but no did you did you
see things or did you hear things or did
you happen to leave yeah tell me what
you saw like
uh
I've never actually like told anyone
anyone else okay they don't know all the
pictures I'm gonna stop you there
because I don't want to be the first
person in this in this context yeah you
knew that somebody
um up close but okay and so keep keep
going here
so yeah I mean I saw all this
all this the the news showed or wasn't
allowed to show honestly yeah
um but anyway I over the last 10 years
I've done a lot of like work
to get rid of or try my best to get rid
of like the
um physical post-traumatic symptoms I
guess you could say
um a lot of stuff started to present
itself like in the spring which was kind
of weird
um like a lack of sleep and all that and
all that was to be expected and we were
warned
um but I guess like 10 years later I'm
realizing that there's a lot of
bitterness I still have for the way that
my family like dealt with
um the situation afterwards I did get I
did get sent to a counselor because I
was honest with my family about like
what I saw and like when everyone was
telling us not to look in One Direction
we were running away like I was curious
so I looked and
um anyway uh so I went to a counselor
but in my head like growing up I had
heard over and over that like
that was weak or maybe I hadn't heard it
but I had internalized that
um that you go to a counselor if you
have a problem and I didn't think that I
had a problem like I I just thought I
would be able to move on
um and so I I didn't really like talk to
anyone about it I just
um now I'm realizing that I shoved it
down and I just
um I guess and now dealing with it 10
years later so it doesn't really go away
but
um what did your what did your mom and
dad do that you're still so bitter your
family I think it's what they didn't do
um tell me about that I so
there was a lack of
conversations about it like we turned to
humor in my family which is really nice
in the moment but I think long term it
has done some damage and it's created
some coping mechanisms in me that like I
just blame on them and I just need to
take some like personal responsibility
for them because
now I'm in my 20s and I wanna tell me
what change that give me two things
you've done as coping mechanisms
um
I never talk about it
and then when I do I only talk about it
in like
trying to find a purpose in the bombing
like I'm just so obsessed just
finding the good in it I guess
um
um tell me though
what are some coping behaviors
are you restrictive with what you need
are you um
to say that yeah I developed like a
really horrible eating disorder
um and then I also just like turned to
success I was like
my fuel I guess
um yeah
and sorry I'm teetering on shoes
and I'm really if you were with me
um and you could feel safe
um I would push you a little bit further
but since we're on the phone you're
sitting by yourself and you can hear me
but
your body can't feel this room right now
okay so I I am intentionally stopping
one or two
uh two questions short okay but I I know
that you can feel that I'm stopping too
yeah I can yeah
so and here's I want you to hear me say
this
um and this is both a disarming thing
and this is also a frustrating thing for
you
the fact that I immediately picked this
isn't written down anywhere I don't you
didn't to my knowledge you didn't put
this in your entry I didn't even read
your letter that you sent I just have a
little cool a clip
um the fact that I picked disorder
eating out of thin air
I want you to know this isn't the
you're you're on a long line of people
who've suffered awful things
yeah and did not have people around that
would
listen to you right and left you to swim
in the middle of the ocean by yourself
and what's super frustrating is they all
look like they were swimming just fine
right next to you
and they worked they're not they're not
either Grace they're not yeah but they
look like the craziest thing is I just
look around me and like I a few other
people in my family like were there
and I just I look at them and I'm like
jealous almost of it's a mirage it's a
mirage it's a mirage it's a mirage
and good for you that you got addicted
to success
and not something else fair right yeah
definitely fair yeah so what's going on
now 10 years later is it media coverage
is it what what is what is bringing this
up now
well my parents did a good job of
covering shielding us from the media
that didn't want us to get obsessed with
it because they did hear that sometimes
people do turn to it didn't get obsessed
with the story I'm gonna tell you they
did the best they could with the info
they had and what they did was
absolutely backwards yeah completely
backwards okay completely backwards okay
um but we we could talk through that in
a second
um yeah or uh um now go ahead sorry um I
was just gonna say that now I
um actually qualified for the Boston
Marathon so I'm running it in a week
so I just I kind of like I just wanted
something to be like mine out of this
you know yeah
um
and yeah
I just I'm setting my expectations like
moderate because who knows
um but I'm just excited that I have the
opportunity to go you know and like
I hope to make it good
this time it's okay grace no one's ever
told you this
it is okay to be terrified out of your
mind
mm-hmm
and it's okay to be so scared that the
day before you get on that plane you
don't go
and it's also okay to go and to run not
your best time but to finish in a active
defiant so profound that few people will
ever understand
what you've done yeah that's how it
feels it feels like I'm
like
it feels like a victory already I guess
yeah um it is I think the reason why I
like really wanted to just like talk to
someone about it is because
not all aspects of the last 10 years
feel Victorious at all you know like and
I expected like 10 years later like why
can't this just be like done you know
because because here's the deal you you
haven't dealt with it
yeah
I know and you don't have a picture of
what that looks like in your house
yeah I'm heartbroken for you
so can I use a
recent tragedy in in my neighborhood to
talk through how I dealt with it with my
little kids
yeah so I'm in Nashville and so we just
had that shooting where that person went
inside and shot kids inside of a little
Christian School right
my seven-year-old and my 13 year old
my seven-year-old we laid down on our
tummies on our stomachs on our
trampoline
outside
and I asked her to tell me what she knew
and what she'd heard and she wasn't at
the school she was down the road but
that was going to be the school that was
her feeder school from her her Pre-K and
so she had people so I asked her to tell
me everything she knew about whatever
she knew then I asked her to tell me
about her feelings
he said she was scared but she knew what
to do and then
she explained a few things to me on
active shooter training that I learned
in a SWAT Operation
and then I wept because I thought my
seven-year-old should not freaking know
this but I didn't hide it from her I let
her see me see what I'm saying see how
different it is
yeah now I didn't let her watch the news
because she's seven
but there's a difference between trying
to Shield somebody and to age
appropriately let them feel and see what
grief looks like
and one step further
I've shown up to scenes and I have
things in my mind that will be there for
the rest of my life just like you right
right yeah the only difference is most
of mine not all but most of them I was
an adult you were a child and so your
body has stamped that
yeah and no adult came to rescue you
no yeah I mean they tried like hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on to stop defending them
you've been defending them your whole
life
you have stop it's not your job
like um I understand that I just I think
my problem with it is putting myself in
their shoes like there's no textbook for
that you know I don't know exactly here
here let me say this
we're not we're not going to blame them
as though there's some retribution or
some like
declaration of war
but we're also going to hold in the
other hand so we're not hating we're not
we're not going to war
but we're gonna hold in the other hand
I was 10.
and somebody that I know and that I love
should have hugged me and said you saw
horrible things tell me about it
you're you weren't safe then but you're
safe now
I'm gonna go to counseling with you
because I'm scared and when they notice
that their teenage daughter
was
skipping meals and losing weight that
they would say hey
I'm gonna come with you
I'm stopping all of our plans that we're
running to you see what I'm saying and
so there is in one hand no we're not
going to beat somebody up because they
were dealing with their own trauma I get
that
and
there was another way they could help it
dealt with it and you have to own both
yeah okay both things are true
you can still love love love them
because they did the best they could
with what they had with the tools they
had in their tool kit and as a kid you
needed more
right okay and so now here we are we're
left with
um
you're in your 20s
yep and what am I going to do now right
yeah
yeah I feel like it's like the Forgotten
thing
um like none of my friends really
remember
um
I just feel like it's very Niche and I
have no one to like relate to about it
um not that I want a relatable problem I
guess no you decided to talk to so I'll
tell you the actual thing that happened
is niche
okay yeah actual thing
but trauma is not Niche at all
right
it's not
and so let me give you a couple of
standard lines that are important grief
demands a witness
you have to say the words out loud of
what you experience and what you went
through
not with me but with somebody you care
and Trust And if that's a new counselor
that's a new counselor
if that's your mom and dad that's your
mom and dad
if that's your sister that's your sister
but you have to you can no longer try to
keep all of this bound and trapped in
your body because you're trying to
protect everybody around you
because when you're 10 you've got this
weird sense in your soul that you didn't
protect somebody
that you did something wrong that you
didn't do enough
funny you say that because I've actually
had this guilt for a while that I ran
away I know I know
Grace you were 10. yeah
if you ran up on a 10 year old right now
who is trying to help what would you
tell them to do
um like find cover get out of here yes
yeah cause you're ten
right
yeah it's unreasonable
um I know but the body does what it does
to keep us safe right right so
now there's some there's some pretty
clear research that says
um and just been my personal experience
too
that just sitting down and Hauling off
and just saying here's everything from
start to finish about my trauma can
actually
re-traumatize your body in a weird way
so the first thing you're going to do is
you're going to get with somebody who's
a trauma specialist and you're gonna
they're gonna it's called seeking safety
you're gonna find a
you're going to teach your body ways to
slowly slowly enter some of these uh
thoughts and memories and
not get overwhelmed by them
okay okay and it's it's the same as
before you run the Boston Marathon you
gotta run two miles it's that and you're
there's it's actually pretty it's a
pretty standard series of we're gonna
meet for three or four times and
practice a couple of ways to
whoo slow our bodies down when it starts
to gear up and there's going to be a
couple of sessions that are in Hell
there's gonna be a couple of sessions
and how do we make light of this new
world how do we go make meaning of all
this
right okay you're trying to make meaning
you're trying to um
here's what you've done in a in such a
beautifully eloquent way
you have laid all the ingredients out
for an incredible
um Texas catfish dinner
and you've got all the people at your
house
and you've got all the lines and bait
you just haven't gone fishing yet
okay so you're trying to make meaning of
something that you haven't fully
processed yet you're holding a 10 year
old accountable for her actions when the
adults in the world around her
left her trying to figure out what to do
next because they they were too busy
trying to survive too
okay
and now you're doing an incredibly Brave
thing
by going back to ground zero and saying
I I won't be conquered by this
this will be a Monumental moment for you
if you don't go through it or if you or
if you do but here's the thing it's not
Rocky 4 like this isn't going to be the
it's not gonna heal you it's not
everything's not gonna be roses and
butterflies after this
yeah but what did I realize get go ahead
and do what
I was just gonna say that's what I
realized from like training for this and
like the reality is this
what's going on in
the change like
I'm ready and I'm
good to run this Marathon
um and I'm excited but I was like oh
wait I'm actually not feeling better
wait nothing's changed in in like I say
this all the time when I'm talking to
like business owners and it sounds trite
and cheesy you get to see it in as close
up as possible which is achievement
never heals you
nope right and you were about to do the
ultimate achievement the ultimate
display of bravery and
um middle fingers to your trauma
and it's still you're gonna cross that
Finish Line you're gonna be so thankful
and then you are still gonna look to
your right and left
yep right
you're still gonna look to your right or
left
yep
don't let that stop you because this
will be this can be a
unbelievably powerful platform from
which to jump off of to go get well
yeah
but at some point you're going to find
yourself sitting in a circle there in
Austin
with a couple of other survivors of
things
and you're going to find out you'll have
very different stories but very similar
lives
and you're gonna have
achieved and accomplished and sought
control over
and for the first time you're gonna feel
safe enough
after a couple of sessions with a
professional
maybe more than a couple you're going to
feel safe enough to finally open your
hands and let go
oh
and then in the safety of those people
who've been there to hell and back
yeah we're just at different coasts
you're going to find Solid Ground for
the first time
since you were 10 or 11.
you'll have bouts of anger with your
parents you're gonna have bouts of great
peace and forgiveness with your family
all the things
I'll be so so I am I'm just blown away
by how proud I am of you
you are stronger than most of us will
ever ever know
so go run your race and if you get close
to it you just can't awesome you got
this far I will high five you all the
way
but if you go through then you finish
the race
you finish it
then you go home
and you exhale
then you look in the mirror and you can
say all right Grace now it's time
you can make that phone call
and you're gonna sit down with somebody
and say I need to talk about some things
I saw when I was 10.
because they still haunt me now
and I need some help teaching my body
that I wasn't okay then
but I'm okay now
I wasn't safe then but I'm safe now
and then we'll be about making meaning
so proud of your grace let me know shoot
me a note when you finish when you cross
that finish line or if you decide to not
run whatever you decide to do let me
know